Texas is calling on private citizens to
assist in securing the Border offering
to dispatch free of charge razor wire to
any private property along the border
one individual said he's working with
CBP to try and stop these people but
they come anyway he said he put up razor
wire and these guys trampled over it
like deer and so he was just like it's
not going to work well they they they
scale fences they scale fences in
minutes I I I was talking to a border
patrol guy one time they had a fence up
and they had video of this they weren't
there at the time but they had put there
was a wall in this area some sort of a
fence and they had specially constructed
a pickup truck with a ladder in the back
of it and a levy system and they just
loaded everyone in the back and they
backed it right up to the wall and they
just laid it right on there they had the
height perfectly and he said Jesse we
timed at 45 seconds there were 12 of
them over the top gone it's gone gone I
know either like what I don't understand
either is what do the people coming into
the United States expect